here in my garage just bought this new
lamborghini here but you know what i
like more than lamborghinis
knowledge dude and webinar wednesday
guys welcome to a segment of the show
where we get scammed so you don't have
to
in the past when talking about gurus
i've talked about their marketing
i've done that stuff i've traditionally
strayed away from going into their
course
partly because i don't want to spend two
thousand dollars also partly because
it's hard to show that because it's
behind a paywall
by that i decided i would do it anyways
and we're gonna have to find a way to
just summarize this for you
and try to get the idea to you without
actually showing the content and our
first guru
is the grand pappy of all gurus the guy
who had the brilliant idea
to pretend he knows something on youtube
get a bunch of poor broke desperate
people to pay him a lot of money
and then try to leverage that into an
actual legitimate business i think tai
lopez is now trying to like buy real
businesses we'll see how that goes
but he got his real start with this
whole internet marketer thing i am like
this genius guru who knows the secret of
health wealth and happiness
you guys all know the ad here in my
garage just bought this uh new
lamborghini here
but you know what i like a lot more than
materialistic things
knowledge but today we're going to be
dissecting what happens
behind the course behind the paywall
so bring down the screen
always feels like that's going to hit me
okay guys 67 steps to success
this is uh what he kicked it off with i
believe you guys are gonna have to tell
me if i'm wrong there
but we're gonna be going through a few
things okay when reviewing this we're
gonna talk about the price
we're gonna talk about what i like what
i don't like should you buy this course
the full review
all that stuff now to start with the
price
uh 67 bucks is what i found it for
with a 67 renewal if you don't can't
cancel i think that's probably pretty
mid-range to low
range i think that's like sort of more
of a tripwire product we're trying to
get you in the tai lopez funnel system
and indeed a lot during the course
you're hearing him talk about the
upsells if you're part of this
closing group if you're part of this
mastermind you should buy
you know this upsell and he always says
oh i don't actually want the money
no no i don't want the money guys i do
it for you so you pay attention
you're not going to pay attention unless
unless you open up that wallet baby
so that's the price now on to the course
itself the first thing you should know
about
this course by mr pez is that it's very
very very long it's 50 hours long which
if you're looking for
value might seem like a good thing but
unfortunately
50 hours does not mean 50 hours of good
content it means 50 hours of tai lopez
basically bloviating
about little anecdotes in his life i
mean nothing of this felt prepared it
felt like he just had
three points and his goal was to hit
like a 30 minute marker
or like an hour-long marker the amount
of just kind of like um
uh well where was i going with this is
ridiculous
luckily i you know i was gonna feel bad
and watch the full 50 hours but tai
lopez
made me feel better and this might be
the only takeaway that i got from his
course
was during the speed reading portion now
we all know tai lopez he's the king of
reading right one book a day
well actually turns out he doesn't read
one book a day he
does something he likes to call speed
skims
a book a day which might mean reading it
for
five minutes might mean reading it for
10 minutes 15 minutes
but basically anything but read it all
the way through
and this is his rationale behind it you
want to get away from
stories stories are what how authors
fill up the pages of the book
so you know yeah that's uh exactly what
ty lopez did in this course
they're just trying to sell their book
they don't want to sell most authors
could write a 10-page book with
everything they know the cliff notes but
they don't want to do that because they
can't
charge you 20 bucks for it yeah the
irony here
is palpable and that's when i realized
i'm not gonna sit through all of this uh
tai lopez justifying a 67
course instead i'll just get like the
main high level points because really it
boils down to in each
lesson he's got 67 lessons it comes down
to like
one thing or like maybe one or two ideas
uh and this is where we come to i guess
the good thing and the bad thing of the
course now
what do i like about tai lopez he
encourages reading i'm never gonna hate
on a guy that encourages reading baby
it's the best mechanism
to self-improvement it's what i tell you
guys to keep doing i probably don't say
it enough
if you have a library card you don't
need any of these idiots
right what i'm trying to tell you you
can get way deeper
ideas you can improve the quality of
your thinking the clarity of your
thinking
all for an incredibly low price so i
i like that about him hopefully he
encourages people to read even his book
list i have no problem with i thought
his book list is pretty good
i've read a lot of the books on there um
and i would wholeheartedly endorse
a lot of them now what do i not like
well
this whole course and this would be sort
of this is getting into like the really
rating part of it the whole course is
reheated
self-help ty lopez speed read
the barnes and noble self-help section
and put it into 50 hours of content
okay 50 hours of him just telling little
stories about uh
grandpa joel salatin or whatever which
by the way
is this man a farmer or isn't he i
recently saw a video where he's
approaching a
horse from behind how did i not know
this but we're supposed to believe he's
a farmer because he's got a hat on
like i'm not even a farmer and even i
know that look can i be a farmer too now
that i
put a straw hat on this is ridiculous
but anyways
that's the biggest problem is that if
you've read self-help
if you've cracked open three four five
books from the self-help section
you already know all this stuff and you
have it from the source material
uh where people have spent years
crafting together
like the amalgamation of decades of
experience right into one or two really
crystallized ideas
or you can have a guy who read it for 15
minutes at the breakfast table
regurgitate it to you
over an hour i mean i think the
difference is clear and this is like
where the value proposition becomes kind
of weak
is that really he's just regurgitating
ideas all the while saying that you
should read but if you read then the
value of tai lopez's course basically
goes to zero
uh and if you just listen to summaries
then you're kind of doing what tai lopez
is saying not to do
which is to be a dilettante another
incredibly ironic part of this course
is he talks a lot about how you need to
drink deeply
from the well of knowledge but tai lopez
seems very interested in not drinking
deeply from the well of knowledge
instead of
drinking very widely from the well of
knowledge i don't know
don't become a dilettante and now the
next thing i want to talk about is
listening to dilettantes see dilettantes
are usually the loudest
oh by the way if you guys don't know
dileton is a fancy way of saying
amateur someone who's just read very
just skim the surface
um and tai lopez's literal approach to
reading is speed
skimming so his message
is don't listen to diletons don't be a
dilettante
uh which i agree a lot with but the
problem is is that tai lopez
is a dilettante telling you not to
listen to diletons once again
i don't know how you get away from the
irony here i would also say here as an
aside on the reading proposition
is that this idea he calls it strip
mining like you're mining for gold you
only want the gold only look for the
gold in the book and as soon as you get
it you like put the book down you don't
care about that book anymore
i think it applies to like a certain
class of business book
but honestly most self-help isn't about
getting as many ideas into your head as
possible
which i think is what he does he like
conflates just
reading a lot of ideas with being really
smart but in actuality it's
internalizing those ideas and applying
them to your life that is the only thing
that matters which is why a lot of
people
can watch hundreds of high-class
performers share their biggest ideas
and they never become a high-class
performer themselves is because you can
take in ideas without actually getting
out of it what they're actually saying
you're not actually internalizing the
ideas and i think strip mining is
the absolute way to make this mistake is
by not really spending time with the
idea like literally just like
oh my gosh what's the site this is what
his idea of speed skimming is it's like
oh look through the book up got that
book it's gone
that's the idea it's a little dumb i
think there's a time for reading broadly
but
eventually if if what i'm getting
actually what he's saying
like you should actually read deeply
then that's not how you do it so
i felt a little confused there now if
you find
any of this ironic uh you're not the
only one and i think
the best way i can explain it is that
you could actually learn a lot from tai
lopez i'm not joking
by watching what he does not what he
tells you to do
so i think if you watch his his uh
original ad
you know here in my garage you could
learn an amazing amount about sales and
marketing from
that right from that if you actually
read like tai lopez reads because even
though he obviously skims a lot of books
he is well read
i think you'd be fine i think you'd do
well i think the problem is is that
what ty lopez does and what he says to
do
are two different things which leads to
a very interesting thing when you're
watching him tell you his life advice
because you're kind of like oh wait
didn't you do that to us oh wait did
aren't you using these tricks on us
like take for example his part where
he's saying don't be the sucker in the
room
while talking to a bunch of people who
bought some reheated
set of ideas that were from a bunch of
people that they should have just read
instead of watch tai lopez's course what
beyond you just consciously going
i'm not going to be the sucker in the
room right you make that conscious
decision
it doesn't mean you won't be the sucker
like
i can't explain to you how funny this is
to me
that he's saying this but okay let's
keep going conscious
changes are well like freud said
the mind is like uh
a iceberg 90 of it is below the water
in your subconscious so the lollapalooza
effect
now i talked he's really jumping around
here what he's quoting now is a charlie
munger thing
la la palooza effect basically it's the
idea that cognitive biases stack on top
of each other
uh to produce a much greater result
small biases can stack on top of each
other
and he's going to basically say don't do
it don't avoid
lalapalooza effect moments okay
talk about this a lot in the ultimate
closing system
sales green belt stuff and you might not
be in that
if you're in an entrepreneur another
option definitely should check that out
because absolutely the best thing
is you always lose at an auction think
of what happens to you
you walk into an auction there's a
person
on stage stat is
the authority bias so automatically even
subconsciously
they are perceived by your subconscious
as an authority because they're
literally physically above you
then they're doing things like going
once going twice
they're creating scarcity and urgency
like
oh if i don't buy this right now i'm
gonna lose it
even though it's something you've lived
your whole life perfectly well with
uh you know perfectly well before you
even heard of it
still an influence on you all these
things
added together create what charlie
monger has
coined the la la palooza effect and the
lollapalooza effect
is a force too powerful a coalescing
of multiple biases
all at once and that is why they say
they don't even put themselves
in that situation it's not something
you can build up willpower around okay
so all of that to say he's saying look
don't get around things that prey on
multiple cognitive biases because you
don't have enough willpower to withstand
it
it's just you're going to lose every
time this is what a webinar is guys
this is what tai lopez's ads do is
they're
la la palooza wonderland it's scarcity
it's appeal to social proof it's like
show look at all the testimonials
it's all of these oh it's pre-recorded
live webinar guys this is all for you i
did this just for you
they're professional marketers that's
what they do and so tai lopez in a class
that you got sold to with the
lollapalooza effect is saying
don't fall for this effect so again
we're left
thinking okay tai what is this it's like
a course
for suckers how not to get suckered and
the first lesson is well you've already
been suckered so you're a sucker it's
like
bizarre to watch this and watch him say
like oh yeah you should try to avoid
these situations if possible
tai lopez's webinars and all these
marketers webinars
are the thing that he's talking about
and not only that he's also
simultaneously saying
that you're the sucker in the room so
yeah that's how i felt this
whole entire course rich
with like sort of irony and though he
had some good ideas that like i agree
with and i've
internalized myself they're all from
books right
they're all from books that most people
if you just go through the basic reading
list of a self-help section you're going
to learn or the basics of a business
book section you're going to learn
and this guy is basically projecting
himself to be the authority on all these
topics despite reading
just very broadly on all of them and
then he says don't listen to diletons
so i don't know take from that what you
will
all in all rating let's get to a rating
i think you guys get the picture
uh i would go ahead and give this
out of 5 stars a 1.5
i would say you know the marketing was
over hyped
if you thought this was going to lead to
a good life really quick obviously it
does not so it doesn't fulfill its side
of the marketing
it's just a bunch of like common sense
frameworks that most people would know
i think the person who should buy this
though i'm going to give you somebody
who should buy this
if you like tai lopez uh and you realize
the marketing is misleading
and you've never read the self-help
section before and you want a broad
swath of it
regurgitated through some long-winded
rants right
uh maybe you have a lot of listening you
need to be doing and you can't stand the
voice of anyone but tai lopez
this might be a good course for you you
know if you want to avoid the
source material and just listen to tai
lopez
this may be a good course for you but
for the rest
rest of you yeah i would say save your
money get a library card
and be well i think that's gonna about
do it thanks for coming to this episode
of webinar wednesday tell me if you
liked it tell me if you hated it tell me
if you want to see more
who do you want to see next week on
webinar wednesday where we get scammed
so you don't have to let me know in the
comments below and as
always i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]